[Music]
you're not going to believe this but we
have to talk about the regressive left
today I've actually been trying to get
away from discussing the regressive left
lately and instead talk about the ideas
of classical liberalism which I believe
in but current events keep dragging me
back I see on social media that people
are using the phrase regressive left a
bit less lately and replacing it with
terms like bigoted ear the control left
or the illiberal left whatever name you
use for this well-meaning yet painfully
misguided set of ideas is largely
irrelevant we needed this phrase to
identify this backwards ideology which
puts groups before people and sometimes
you need a label to get people to
understand an idea the portion of the
left which is no longer progressive
meaning for progress but regressive
meaning going backwards has been
identified and now we're clearly
bringing people to the side of reason
all of you who talk about this with
friends and family who use the
regressive left hashtag on Twitter and
share these videos are part of this
political awakening yes it seems like
these backwards ideas are getting
stronger in some circles but at the same
time finally for the first time in a
long time those of us who are liberal
and open to new ideas are coming
together and being heard whether or not
you like Trump his win was a huge
rejection of the identity politics of
the left but don't take my word for that
Bernie Sanders said it himself the only
thing which can replace the regressive
descent of the left is a return to true
liberalism a liberalism which defends
free speech and expression a liberalism
that is for liberty and rights of the
individual and most importantly a
liberalism that is one for human liberty
I now believe that this regressive
ideology is the biggest threat to
freedom and Western civilization that
exists today with the rise of Trump and
the constant comparisons they make of
him to Hitler the left now has the
perfect boogey man to use to excuse
anything if your opponent is a vile
racist then you can use violence and any
means necessary to stop them the
regressive left
already begun using violence as a tactic
and I fear that that's just getting
started if you're only now getting up to
speed on what the regressive left is
allow me to recap quickly the regressive
control the liberal left whatever you
want to call it is a group of people who
place identity usually based on
immutable characteristics in a pecking
order of social importance such as race
gender and religion where victimhood is
the highest virtue to be had this
oppression Olympics allows groups to
compete for who is the most depressed
thus the most virtuous and if someone
isn't as oppressed as you then you have
full authority to oppress them
accordingly so black lives matter can
protest the gay rights march in Toronto
white gay men can be banned from leading
LGBT organizations on college campuses
pro-life women can be kicked out of
women's rights marches and so on this
backwards ideology which demands we
judge each other not on the content of
our character but on the color of our
skin or some other baked-in trait puts
the collective ahead of the individual
it loves all of its minority groups to
behave as monolith so if you're a true
individual meaning you don't subscribe
to the ideas that the groupthink has
attributed to you based on those
immutable characteristics you must be
cast out many of the guests on my show
have suffered from this backwards
backlash ayaan Hirsi Ali
Maajid Nawaz Sarah Haider and Ali rizvi
all have felt abandoned by the left
because they speak out about the
problems within Islam they dare to fight
for a more tolerant more truly
progressive Islam in tune with the
modern society and basic liberal values
and for that they're labeled bigots or
worse the Southern Poverty Law Center
even labeled Maajid as an anti Muslim
extremist in reality maje is a former
Islamist who has devoted his life to
trying to reform Islam from the inside
to try to reconcile his faith with the
modern world fighting for gays and
atheists and women and any other free
thinkers living under theocratic rule
for this he is called a porch monkey and
other
vile names by supposed progressive while
at the same time he's admired by many on
the right for being outspoken this is
the absolute height of absurdity but it
all makes sense when you value groups
over individuals the individual must be
sacrificed at the altar of the
collective so when any of these people
dare speak out and call for true
tolerance they find their tolerance met
with intolerance the less loves
diversity and skin color just not
diversity in thought
of course this regressive ideology isn't
just tied to Islam at all my guest this
week is Larry elder a black conservative
who has had every label and smear thrown
at it again like with the previous
guests I just mentioned these slurs come
from people on the Left who would rather
silence and dismiss their opponents than
actually engage them in an honest way
people often ask me which interview I've
done that's changed my views the most
and I almost always say that it was the
first time I sat down with Larry elder
he challenged my views on systemic
racism as well as the need for strong
family and was one of the people that
helped sell me on why small government
is important if you haven't seen the
video will post the link right down
below larry challenged me and i wasn't
ready so i can't say that it was my best
moment on camera but i listened and
learned and just as importantly we
didn't edit any of it out so i'm looking
forward to picking up where larry and i
left off and as for where we left off
this is where i feel there might be
nothing left for me on the modern
american left you all know most of my
positions on important issues i'm for
free speech even for white supremacist
Richard Spencer to speak and not get
punched in the face has happened just a
couple days ago and I'm still a
card-carrying liberal by the way I'm for
gay marriage on pro-choice on Pro
legalization of marijuana I'm against
the death penalty and the list goes on
at the same time though I'm against this
oppression Olympics I'm against safe
spaces and trigger warnings against
labeling all my opponents bigots and
racists and I'm against D platforming
speakers especially at colleges where
ideas are meant to be challenged and
debated I'm also for states rights for
following the Constitution and most
importantly for having a limited
government that gets out of
the way so that you can live your life
to the fullest I've said a few times on
the show that defending my liberal
principles has become a conservative
position interestingly I've also heard
conservatives like Andrew Clavin and
Dennis Prager say that they are
conservative because they really are
liberals this is where we might get lost
in the definition of liberal in the
modern sense first classical liberals so
if you're still confused about that
check out a video I did a couple weeks
ago called why I'm a liberal we'll put a
link to it right down below the point is
that if the issues I care about most
free speech rights of the individual and
limited government designed to maximize
liberty now have almost nothing to do
with the modern left my positions
basically haven't changed but I've
watched as my team has gone off the deep
end
the battle of ideas always gets to a
tipping point and I sense that we're
closing in on one right now
if we can't rein in this madness on the
left then Donald Trump will be all too
happy to show them his authoritarian
side both sides are ramping up for a
showdown that seems incredibly obvious
to me so while I absolutely believe that
the new center filled with liberals
conservatives and libertarians and
others is rapidly growing maybe I've
lost the left and maybe that's okay but
to end this direct message I now kick
this back to you guys if you're liberal
is there anything left for you on the
left or are you left out is it now the
conservative position to truly deliver
all let me know in the comments right
down below and we'll see if there is
anything left to discuss
[Music]
you